hello and welcome to this video oh this
is Grand Master Impaler old tired and
very very weak yeah I don't know it's a
pretty good rating for very very weak
but will seem to 467 yeah sideline here
against the bank oh yeah this is this is
a playable way for black would be five
just shutting down everything hmm I
don't know it's my piss configuration
great here I think I'll take it the
closed position I don't like that much
that looked a little bit too simple for
black to get some activity going be sure
the f-4s potentially even creature have
six some hmm to go maybe ask the Queen
what she's up to okay hmm yeah taking on
a three would be annoying yeah at least
I'm getting a square 1c3 here but should
be seven doesn't work right okay I have
a five maybe a 5-2 okay quickly play it
again it seems like it's very easy for
him this is this position 95 maybe
ok so it doesn't take it hmm that's a
good decision I didn't see it it doesn't
have to take okay I can take before now
but then he's got night to see Five
coming mmm now anyway I think otherwise
he will take the five it's also not
great yeah so take this doesn't look
good but there is some pressure 94 maybe
might be able to win see for now it at
least them I think this is giving me
some compensation ok so takes on e6 all
night be fire from 9 p-5 it's the more
challenging way of playing I can also go
a six I know ok i go to be five
just a tech t6 and it can take these six
takes you five not sure about it but
other other moves probably won't do the
job so I'm taking it
you
he has to check it right what is there
some other move I don't see another move
I know it's funny they sometimes play
the most committal moose super quickly
where there are five most possible and
when it looks like this just one move it
takes a while and okay so I'm just going
back I guess yeah let's go back and see
five keep keep that pawn a six in Bishop
Bishop b5 a six in Bishop b5 probably
wins stuff no Bishop b5 immediately
there should be five immediately that
will win the exchange very likely yep so
but I don't want to take with this or
maybe I want I have Bishop a6 as well I
think this is stronger should a 60 s
Bishop c4 no gypsy for okay i don't care
i just take take everything here to see
one now the thing that is slightly
dangerous here for me as others pawns if
I lose the B porn this this would be
would be a problem at the time yeah so
um what to do Bishop c5 queen 86 queen a
six to grab the pawn and have a dispute
g7
hmm i think i would like to trade this
it goes to g7 and go back
I don't want to draw I just okay that's
the move I should have paid more
attention to not good not good time
morning Jim not easy not easy to win
those pawns can be quite dangerous I get
to have six though I think Jack 48 hmm I
will see defending this now don't see it
maybe I managed after all
yes got no moves no moves for you black
resigns yeah I still I think I didn't
play it well I'm from a technical point
of view um if we um yeah if we start
right here it's a it's a very tough
position this black is very active so I
mean black can not be in any danger here
so okay this one he was playing in sand
moose the whole time the computer gives
this this this is good for blood no it
makes some sense this is weak and the
beep horn is dangerous there was a
missed opportunity but as I said he just
played instantly all the time so how can
he find the best moves so it's difficult
okay here he had 97 that's a possibility
that i didn't even mention during shaggy
video I I wasn't it wasn't sure what
what happens here 95 yeah okay it was
possible but I was happy that my pieces
now are coordinated and this doesn't
look bad yeah this allows 96 now he has
to do something differently this is not
what the computer gives keeps the
material yeah this is this is a pawn and
now yeah i also have looks you one here
that's what the engine gives and now
because i still have this so bad this at
this particular
I didn't see that one and here this is
not easy former from a technical point
of view I mean in blitz chess at least
this is ok I can do that but what I
should play here is a six this is a move
that yeah I should have seen during the
game this keeps a seven as a target and
this makes quite a difference I think
now this looks like a pretty pretty
clean win the way I played it it wasn't
great because i blundered the b5 pond oh
I had Queen f3 year oh I saw the idea
but just one move later the engine still
things I'm completely winning so maybe
it wasn't wasn't that terrible yeah yeah
it gives a complete win all of the time
my Pollard had overlooked rook cd5 of
course it was that's all that's the
decisive one now as route 28 he cannot
cannot prevent that and then he gets um
yeah basically gets checkmated of one
loses the Queen yet with this issues on
the on the back leg okay hope you
enjoyed the video thanks for watching